Film Courage: Is there a specific kind of
story a first-time screenwriter should make?
Larry Wilson: Ah…Yes!
What that story is and it’s not that cliche
of ‘Write what you know’ because I’ve
never written what I “know.”
I write fantastical worlds and supernatural
stories and all of that.
But write what you feel and what’s in your
heart and write something that means something
to you.
And you know I was a script reader for gosh…probably
a decade.
And I was reading 7-8 scripts a week.
And the rare one was the great script.
And when I found that, this was a very exciting
day at the office.
And sometimes the really terrible scripts,
they were fun because they were so God-awful.
But the ones that got really exhausting and
really irritating as a script reader who has
to read a script, synopsize it, write a comment
about it, and then pick up another one, read
it and synopsize it, were ones who you could
tell were written by people who were looking
at what last year’s hit was and trying to
imitate it.
And those were deadly!
And they weren’t good.
They weren’t bad.
They were safe and mediocre.
And any young writer or old writer, anyone
who is just starting to write, write something
that you feel.
Write something that comes from the heart.
And people may not think that BEETLEJUICE
is a personal movie but it’s an intensely
personal movie.
It was intensely personal for Michael [the
co-writer].
And I didn’t know that I had a theme until
I had enough work to realize I had a theme.
And almost everything I’ve written are about
broken families who are put back together
in some bizarre way because I came from a
broken family.
So I like to think that my work has a sense
of heart and a sense of compassion and a sense
of humanity.
No matter how bizarre it is, no matter how
weird the worlds get.
And you’ve got to write something that you
feel, that you have some passion for or why
do it?
It’s just too hard.
It’s not an easy job.
I personally can’t imagine saying “Well,
this was a hit.
So now I am going to write my version of that.
It’s not really what I care about, what
I feel.
But I can imitate it well enough.”
I can’t imagine spending a year of your
life doing that.
But people do it all the time.
And people usually write mediocre scripts.
Film Courage: Is being safe something that
has never appealed to you?
Larry Wilson: I don’t know how…in my career
and in my life!
Safe hasn’t factored into it.
Not always the best decision, maybe?
But I sort of like jumping off cliffs.